okay in our first news story uh china
has declared that crypto transactions
are illegal uh according to
the ccp's statement and a bunch of news
coverage uh and there this is part of
the continuing crackdown on obviously uh
cryptocurrency virtual currencies and uh
early this morning the ccp released a
proclamation titled quote notice on
further preventing and disposing of the
risk of hype in virtual currency trading
um any quotes we're going to provide uh
from the ccp in this news segment uh
were transferred by google translate so
take it for what it's worth um people
are
you know doing this online and trying to
translate it in real time and it's kind
of a breaking news story so uh quote
recently virtual trading virtual
currency trading hype activities have
risen disrupting economic and financial
order breeding illegal and criminal
activities such as gambling illegal
fundraising fraud pyramid schemes and
money laundering seriously endangering
the safety of people's property
to enforce these rules china has created
a new coordination mechanism across 10
government
organizations from the supreme court to
the cyberspace administration the ccp
will be investing in additional
resources to be able to track on-chain
activity for a rapid response mechanism
for early warning information
transmission verification disposal so i
know you know we've talked about this
over and over again
china's an authoritarian country they
can change the rules anytime they want
there is no democratic process and i
have been saying this over and over
again for the better part of a decade
now
um what people don't understand is if
china is going to ban student uprisings
uh certain publications social media
platforms and religions right just look
at all that evidence
religion
freedom of speech freedom of religion uh
freedom of assembly all of these things
are our constitution as critical to what
we do here in the united states
um
why would you think they would leave out
money
money is really important and so here we
are china let uh cryptocurrency
kind of exist in a gray zone for a long
time and we know they banned all the
bitcoin miners uh bitcoin obviously
survived that so that's great uh for the
bitcoin community uh even though all
those servers were had to be removed
and now we're seeing actual transactions
now they didn't say
that holding cryptocurrency is illegal
yet obviously that will be the next shoe
to drop um and we've we've covered this
you know for a while what you can take
away from this is
the authoritarian governments uh will be
able to act quicker and without much of
a process than democracies so we're
going to see this across many different
uh aspects of society let's take the
aspect of society of wealth disparity
we've seen great wealth disparity
because of alibaba or amazon right
on two different continents two
different countries same situation one
individual jeff bezos the other
individual jack ma both accumulate
massive power both accumulate massive
wealth here in the united states we have
people complaining about it we have
people complaining about capital gains
tax treatments people taking loans
against their equity and it's a big
massive discussion and a process in
china they just said you know what you
can no longer be that rich we need to
have we need to spread the wealth around
and they basically just decided to do
wealth redistribution and they pressed
the button
and that is uh something we're now
seeing with um
privacy
in america we're having a vibrant debate
about you our privacy and you know
amazon versus google and facebook and
china just decided to press the button
no longer can you collect this
information and the government has to
have the information and you have to go
through a cyber security audit you get
the idea then we look at cryptocurrency
they did the same thing we look at kids
on social media they're just going to
ban kids for being on social media we're
going to have a messy debate between
facebook executives researchers
our elected officials the public and the
press about
should we allow kids on instagram social
media tick tock etc they just push the
button no more that's it
and if you look at video games another
example they think it's bad for kids the
studies show too much of it is bad for
kids of course a little bit is probably
not a problem uh you can make your own
decision then you said hey these are the
new rules and
you can
look at this one of two ways you can
look at it and say well they're going to
get to the right answer quicker
but
if you
dictate to people this is the right
answer and they don't get the chance to
process it and be part of the debate
it's kind of a crummy feeling right it
just makes you a slave to the state and
the government and this is going to
backfire in a major way in china if
china keeps squeezing their own citizens
you can't play video games you can't use
social media you can't do cryptocurrency
you can't
practice a religion these are the things
that ferment a revolution and i actually
think what's happening in china right
now as they crack down and they crack
down and they tighten their grip the
more they tighten their grip the more of
the freedom fighters and the more of the
rebels are going to slip through their
fingers
and you know it reminds me of something
fred wilson said in a documentary called
banking on bitcoin back in 2016. let's
just play this 26 second clip and i'll
give you my comments on the other side
the lesson from the internet is anything
that china bans invest in
and that's a joke but
the us
allows google to operate here allows
twitter to operate here allows bitcoin
to operate here allows facebook to
operate here chinese government doesn't
allow any of those companies to operate
the way they operate in this country or
at all
uh it's about freedom
ultimately yeah fred's exactly right
friend of the pod friend of mine brett
and his wife joanne wilson and i worked
together at siliconangle reporter back
in the day we built that company
together and uh had a great experience i
was actually a consultant for fred
wilson at acme ventures back in the day
the precursor to flatiron and i read two
business plans one of them was from
beverly hills internet which became
geocities which they invested in was
their first big unicorn and the other
one was for american cyber casting which
produced the spot and uh masay yoshi-san
back in 1995-96 when i was 24 years old
wrote read my coverage spelling errors
and grammar errors and all that i gave
to fred wilson and jerry colon and they
said he really appreciated my insights
into those i don't know where those
documents are but i almost became a
venture capitalist instead of a
publisher uh back in the day shout out
to fred wilson and jerry colonna two
great mentors and friends of mine
so this is uh what's happening right now
and i think that's the big picture now
as we narrow down what's happening here
i think
again
two different types of countries have
two different approaches uh two
changing the rules or setting the
standards for society an authoritarian
country it's top down they're dictators
i know a lot of people are neophytes to
you know the arc of history and world
history but you know i've been around
long enough to know
that in a dictatorship you know they may
pretend that it's benevolent uh but you
know it's not right
you know that when they get the chance
uh they're gonna slam their fist down
and it doesn't matter who's underneath
it and they see any threat to power
they're gonna take action
i bought jean michel oscar i kid you not
did i buy the whole painting of course
not i don't have that kind of cash
basquiat is one of my favorites
beautiful art and i've always wanted to
own and have exposure to this class of
art how did i do it masterworks
masterwork securitizes million dollar
paintings sometimes tens of millions of
dollars as in this case to allow any
investor access to the blue chip art
market you buy shares in the painting
just like you'd buy shares in a company
like uber or tesla or spacex and now i
own a couple of basis points in a
baskeon
feels pretty great i gotta be honest but
i don't have to worry about it i don't
have to insure it i don't have to deal
with it i just get the gains art has
been an amazing alternative investment
contemporary art pieces have
outperformed the s p by a hundred
seventy four percent from 1995 to 2020
according to masterworks research and
masterworks is the first platform giving
everyday investors access to this
exclusive world and if you want to join
the fun go to massworks.io slash twist
masterworks dot io slash twist you skip
the waitlist and hey listen if you're
into art and you want to have access to
this you can make a small bet just like
jkl did so see the important disclosures
at masterworks dot io slash disclaimer
masterworks dot io disclaimer and you
know you should be diversified you don't
want to have everything you own in one
class whether it's startups or art
unless you're like really done your
diligence i like to have a nice balanced
portfolio okay let's get back to this
amazing episode